madeleine roy c'est vous qui avez mené
cette longue enquête vous venez
d'entendre monsieur péladeau il a répété
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas eu de créations
de sociétés d'entreprise dans les
paradis fiscaux
quand il était à la tête de quebecor
alors que lui répondez-vous à votre
terre je continue de trouver ça étonnant
bon ils ont publié quebecor a publié un
petit communiqué disant 3d compagne et
vous avez mentionné
on n'y aurait pas de lien on les a pas
créé on les a pas détenus on ne sait pas
utiliser ça se peut il y avait dans ma
liste des compagnies ou le lien du ser
établir mais il ya beaucoup de
compagnies le lien est très claire et
des compagnies qui ont été créés après
que monsieur péladeau est était
président des compagnies jean le tableau
ici là îles vierges britanniques
quebecor world investment juin 2000 et
prémery quebecor luxembourg mars 2006
wong kar waï en décembre 2003 suisse
quebecor world is l'anzhi reykjavik sa
c4 exemple de compagnies qui ont été
créés après que monsieur péladeau est
était président et après qu'il eut
acheté parce que dans le reportage le
suivi know it easy ou et des fois on a
acheté des compagnies avaient déjà
départ a dit ban
quebecor world a été formé à 99 après
l'achat d'un imprimeur américaine donc à
partir de 99 ce qui a été créé c'est pas
des choses qui venait de la seule sa a
été créée est-ce qu'il l'ignorait pétain
il dit qu'il n'était qu'un
administrateur et long qu'il ne pouvait
pas agir là dessus bord
ça reste à voir si un administrateur a
sonné mais lier comme ça peut-être mais
en 2004 il est devenu président de
quebecor world passes allaient tellement
mal qui a dit je vais aller mal occupé
moi même
il y a été lors de moins gros 2 1 il ne
peut pas ne pas avoir vu qu'ils avaient
des compagnies dans îles vierges
luxembourg su s et c est ce qui les a
fermés est ce qui les a utilisés en tout
cas ils pouvaient le quand il nous a
déclaré en début de campagne pendant que
j'étais directeur je n'ai jamais eu de
filiales dans les paradis fiscaux à
moins de considérer que quebecor world a
fait pas parti québécois alors ça fais
partie québec car comme quebecor media
et vidéotron font partie
les cas il était l'actionnaire
majoritaire de québec a le gestionnaire
estime que je continue d'être étonné par
certaines déclarations étonné est ce que
certaines choses qui le disent
aujourd'hui qu'ils peuvent vous y
branlée passé après cette enquête
non au contraire la lumière ce fut parce
que ça fait des mois que je regarde ma
liste de paradis fiscaux et que je
l'entends dire je n'ai jamais fuir les
paradis fiscaux que je me dis et ce qui
met quelque chose qui m'échappe
hélas je crains qu'ils considèrent que
quebecor world qui a constitué à 80%
jets d'affaires de la compagnie parents
des années il considère que c'était pour
lui sceaux s'était pas main mais je
comprends mieux peu les déclarations je
fait qu'on n'a jamais touché aso nous et
je le répète on l'a dit plusieurs fois
aujourd'hui
vous aviez soumis des questions à
monsieur péladeau il a refusé d'y
répondre et il a refusé de répondre
aujourd'hui - c'est çà et là on se donne
des réponses par reportage interposé
alors la suite de votre enquête donc
jeudi à une seule enquête merci beaucoup
madeleine persie je joue en maintenant
notre chef de bureau à québec sébastien
toutes ces révélations place pierre karl
péladeau dans une position délicate sur
toute cette question des paradis fiscaux
oui surtout que la position de son parti
c'est de se présenter comme le champion
de la lutte contre les paradis fiscaux
contre l'évasion fiscale l'évitement
fiscal
à tel point que le parti québécois a
poussé très fort pour qu'une commission
parlementaire qui se tiennent sur le
sujet ici à l'assemblée nationale il a
même menacé les banques de leur envoyer
des super nanas pour les forcer à venir
témoigner dans cette commission
parlementaire alors il ya une
contradiction apparente entre le
discours politique du parti québécois et
de monsieur péladeau et les actions les
gestes qu'il a posés comme
administrateur de quebecor faut faire
attention par contre c'est toujours
délicat de porter un regard sur des
événements qui se sont produits il ya
une quinzaine d'années mais quand même
constat qu'on peut faire ce soir c'est
que ce qui devait être la force de
pierre karl péladeau ses qualités
d'administrateur de gestionnaires
deviennent à tout le moins pour cette
semaine
caillou dans son soulier parce qu'il
doit justifier expliquer des décisions
qu'il a prises comme administrateur de
quebecor et c est ce que tout ça ne
l'empêchent pas d'imposer les enjeux
qu'il veut défendre
contrôlez l'ordre du jour politique
comme on dit oui une partie de l'art de
la politique c'est comme vous le dites
de contrôler le message de contrôler les
enjeux les vos politiciens passent des
heures selon des jours à essayer
d'identifier un message ce matin le
message de pierre karl péladeau ça
devait être les compressions dans les
centres de la petite enfance
il a même participé à une minute une
manifestation un enchaînement collectif
autour d'un cpe mais aussi rapidement
vous pouvez dire paradis fiscal
le message de monsieur péladeau a pris
le bord il a dérapé
la semaine dernière c'était la même
chose monsieur péladeau tenait un caucus
avec les députés du parti québécois
aussi rapidement vous ayez pu dire
institut sur la souveraineté le message
de critiques du gouvernement a dérapé
alors monsieur péladeau sait qu'il a
perdu la semaine dernière
il sait qu'il perd le contrôle du
message cette semaine aussi il aimerait
beaucoup plus que je vous parle ce soir
des compressions dans le cpe de l'état
du réseau de l'éducation vont encore de
la simulation d'économies mais il sait
que jusqu'à la fin de la semaine jusqu'à
vendredi parce que le reportage diffusé
jeudi
il va devoir parler de paradis fiscal
malgré une tournée des régions qu'il
entreprend cette semaine